l'actualité politique du week end à bord
l'université d'été du modem à la
grande-motte cette fois ci s'est dit
françois bayrou tend la main aux
socialistes six mois les élections
régionales une question qu'il a débattu
hier soir avec les militants caroline le
chanteur michel anglade séance
d'explication et jeu de questions
réponses le virage à gauche du modem
inquiète les militants certains voient
rouge après l'apparition de la numéro
deux du parti au côté de robert je ne
comprends pas qu'un communiste et pis de
venir dans le monde envoyé en madame de
sarnez sur un mistral avec robert hue ça
m'a fait bondir j'en ai pas dormi de la
nuit un joli tout de suite à françois
bayrou de rachid le parti orange n'a pas
prévu de changer de couleur pardon mais
il se lance dans un vaste chantier
qu'elle sait il y a des gens qui ne
supportent pas ce qui se passe
simplement il ya un moment où il faut
construire oui très majoritairement avec
des gens modérés et avec des gens
récemment converti à la modération
un brin d'ironie et malgré la pluie hier
soir l'ambiance est restée plutôt apaisé
j'ai trouvé que c'était bien c'était
rigolo par moments près et puis en même
temps c'était je n'ai je n'ai jamais été
inquiet c'est une famille politique où
les gens sont pas là par hasard
françois bayrou prend le pouls de ses
militants mais aussi de ses vice
présidents
certains réclament davantage de
collégialité au menu de cette deuxième
journée les élections régionales et la
question cruciale des alliances main
tendue vers la gauche pourquoi pas main
tendue vers europe écologie
moi je pense que ça aurait beaucoup de
sens je crois qu'il est important que le
modem surtout définit ce qu'est son
projet et que alors que le modem a fait
cet effort de sortir de l'udf qui était
la béquille de l'ump est bien modem ne
devienne pas la béquille du ps bâtira un
grand pôle social la démocrate et
écologiste c'est ce que devraient
confirmer demain françois bayrou lors de
son discours de clôture des
clarifications au stratégique
après deux mois de silence